[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hello, everyone.
My name is Yukio Lippit.
I'm the faculty director of the
arts at the Radcliffe Institute
and a co-organizer
of this conference.
And it's my pleasure
to welcome you
to the final panel of
today's conference,
which is titled "Gender,
Media, and Popular Culture."
We have a terrific
group of speakers
that are going to address a
complex nexus of problems.
And we have the
perfect moderator
to introduce and moderate them,
professor Mary Jo Kane, whose
full biography is listed in
the booklet, the conference
booklet.
But I'll just say here she is
professor of sports sociology
and the director
of a unique center,
the Tucker Center for
Research on Girls and Women
in Sports, at the University
of Minnesota, which
she had a hand in founding.
Her list of publications on the
subject of sports in society
is extensive.
And her contributions to
sports education in general
are really immense
and multifaceted.
All of us, as
educators at Radcliffe,
hold her in the highest regard.
So without further ado,
I'd like to introduce
Mary Jo Kane and the panelists.
- Before I begin
my final remarks,
I want to say that over 30 years
of being in higher education
and going to countless
conferences--
and as the director
of the Tucker Center,
hosting a few
conferences myself--
I know event management.
And I just have to say that I
told this to Becky last night.
When you come here to
the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study at Harvard
University as an outsider,
you are dealing with the A team.
So how about a round of
applause for all those folks.
[APPLAUSE]
The opening sentence on the
invitation to this conference
reads as follows: the
degree to which sports
permeate societies has
never been greater,
making it a revealing lens
through which to understand
many contemporary issues.
The contemporary
issues that we are
going to examine this afternoon
is sport, media, and gender.
I'll set the stage with a
general critique of what sport
media scholarship has produced
over the last 40 years
regarding media
representations and how
they impact the way we
think about female athletes,
as part of a larger
critical analysis regarding
sport, gender, and power
in the post Title IX era.
My remarks will be followed
by Professor Mike Messner, who
is a sociologist at the
University of Southern
California, who
will discuss change
and continuity in the coverage
of men's and women's sports.
Mike's remarks will be followed
next by Professor Rachael
Joo, who is in American
Studies at Middlebury College.
And she will discuss how
female golfers are represented
in U.S. And Korean media, while
exploring links among gender,
race, and nationalism.
Finally, Kavitha
Davidson, from espnW,
will highlight the
decisions the media make
that affect representations
of women's sports,
ranging from which
sports they cover to how
they frame that coverage.
And then we all know the drill.
After we're done, I'll lead
us and have the panel members
talk for about 15 minutes.
And then we will open
it up for a public Q&A.
Over the last four decades,
sport media scholars
have amassed an increasingly
sophisticated body
of knowledge regarding
the symbiotic connections
among sport, gender, and power.
We moved beyond
descriptive content
analysis-driven
studies, which examined
the frequency of coverage given
to women's and men's sports,
to scholarly lines of
inquiry that were grounded
in critical feminist theory.
This particular
analytic framework
argues that society
is structured
around a series of inequitable
relationships of power
where women are systematically
devalued and marginalized.
We made the empirical
and theoretical case
that sports serve as an ideal
site for the connections
between gender and power because
sport vigilantly maintains
gender as hierarchically
ordered, but more
importantly grounded
in the physical body
and thus perceived
as biologically,
meaning inherently, based.
We also argue that media
representations play a critical
role in perpetuating
these notions
of a biologically-based,
gendered hierarchy--
where in spite of
the enormous progress
that has been made two
generations removed from Title
IX, women remain
second-class citizens in one
of the most powerful economic,
social, and political
institutions on this planet.
In some, as Mike Messner has
insightfully pointed out,
female athletes and media
representations of their body
became and remain
contested terrain.
Let me just take a
few minutes to talk
about what we, as
sport media scholars,
have amassed again over
the last forty years.
And we've found two
overarching patterns
of media representations
given to women's sports.
First, female athletes are
significantly underrepresented
in that, for example, even
though 43% of all scholarship
athletes in college sports
nationwide are women,
they receive only about 2%
to 4% of overall coverage
across the vast and ubiquitous
sport media landscape.
And Mike Messner's work,
his longitudinal work,
will point that out.
Second, within this
coverage, female athletes
are significantly
more likely than males
to be portrayed off the court,
out of uniform, and in highly
sexualized poses.
Let me just give you
a couple of examples
of what I mean by that.
That's also Lindsey Vonn.
And next, from the
team sport of soccer.
And then look at how
you feel when you
see that they're juxtaposed.
So let me close by
highlighting the impacts
of these kinds of images.
I began my remarks
by pointing out
that sports serves as a
critical site for reproducing
notions of gender and
power differences.
But what is often overlooked--
and this is absolutely
essential for any
analysis going forward--
is how sports can also
serve as a critical site
for subverting these very
ideologies and practices.
When media images and
narratives emphasize women
as highly skilled and
physically powerful athletes,
they are directly
challenging and profoundly
threatening to
belief systems that
have and continue to relegate
sports women to the sidelines.
And that is because when we
sexualize female athletes,
it takes away from an incredibly
powerful and reaffirming moment
of women's physical
capacities and turn it
into something that is
a moment of triviality
and marginalization.
I would suggest to
you that until we
see a plethora of images that
reflect the reality of women's
participation, they will
never receive the full respect
and admiration that they
not only richly deserve,
but that they have also earned.
Thank you.
- Thank you very
much for inviting me.
And I echo what Mary
Jo and other people
have all been saying about how
wonderfully organized this day
has been and how fabulous the
previous sessions have been.
My comments will build on,
I think, and possibly echo
some of the points that were
made earlier this morning.
It's great especially--
I just want to mention--
as a former basketball
player and someone
who loves basketball still,
to be in this building.
It's fun to imagine
this as a place
where basketball
was once played.
And to sort of hear
the echoes of the ball
slapping on the
wood floors here,
I really love that sense
of history as well.
I wanted to start with
a little anecdote.
I'm going to talk about more
longitudinal study of sports
media that I've
been involved in.
But I wanted to start with
an anecdote that kind of sets
the stage for me that
happened just a few days ago.
I live in South
Pasadena, California,
and I do my grocery shopping at
a grocery store called Ralphs.
And often when I'm at
the checkout stand,
people are talking sports.
And some of the
checkers sometimes
will all dress in football
jerseys during the Super Bowl.
Or they'll be talking
about USC and UCLA.
Who's going to win the big game?
And if it's basketball
season, they're
always talking about the men.
And so I will sometimes say to
one of the checkers, well yeah,
I like the UCLA and USC rivalry.
But I'm really interested
in the women's game.
I go to all of the USC
women's basketball games.
And usually that comment
falls pretty flat.
And "oh" is kind of
the usual answer.
And then they give me my change.
I was standing there,
though, the other day
after the semifinals of
the women's tournament.
And in the checkstand
behind me, I
heard this man saying
to the checker,
did you see that game yesterday?
I thought he was going to be
talking about something else.
But it was the game
that I watched.
He said, that little
Morgan William just nailed
that shot and just put
the dagger in UConn.
And then the checker said,
yeah, I watched that.
That was so great, wasn't it?
And then I think I hurt my
neck whiplashing around.
I want to get into
this conversation.
I said, yeah, wasn't that great?
She was so awesome, but even
more so in the game before
against Baylor where she hit 41.
And one of them had watched that
too, and we bonded around that.
And I thought, wow, this
is quite an amazing moment.
And I think it's
a sign of change.
One anecdote, but
it's a sign of change
that reflects the fact
that women's basketball--
not just the final four, but
throughout the regular season
now we can watch women's
basketball on television.
Where I live, there's
a Pac-12 network.
We can watch regular
season games,
which helps to build
a storyline that
creates an interest
and a fan base for when
the final four happens.
20 or 30 years ago, if
you watched the final four
for the women, it would have
been a tape delay, really poor
production values,
with no opportunity
to watch regular season games.
And it's like it's dropping
in from Mars into your living
room.
So now, it's quite a
different experience.
On the other hand, I think
all the things that we've
heard today, and
some of the data
that I'll give you
in a moment, suggest
that it's not quite time for
the feminist victory lap.
I've been working with some
colleagues around this idea
that instead of thinking
of the social changes that
have taken place over
the last 30 years
in sport and in other
parts of our society,
we've neither
experienced a revolution
nor have we experienced this
sort of stalled revolution
that some people
are talking about.
But really instead
we're experiencing
what I call social change
that is incomplete.
And many of these sort of
bullets you see up here
are repeating things that
have been said today.
But in youth sport, an
area that I've studied,
there's been this
huge boom of girls.
And yet there is this continued
inequities in sex segregation
and other parts of youth
sports that really have not yet
transformed.
In particular, the
new research that's
developing on transgender kids
and their families struggle
to get into a binary
divided youth sports system.
Sports leadership, as several
people have pointed out today,
at the high school
and college level
is still largely in male hands--
athletic directors,
head coaches.
And in the media,
we see an expansion,
as I said, in some areas, like
the coverage of women's hoops,
which I really applaud as a fan.
But on the other
hand, we see still
continued silences and
poor quality coverage
of women's sports.
So I'm really kind of
interested in understanding
that unevenness
of social change--
why and how social
change happens
more rapidly in some sectors
and not so much in others.
And sports media is
just one of the places I
think we can think about that.
I'm going to talk about a study
that a couple of people here
today, Donna Lopiano and
others, have referenced
that I've done over the years.
It's a 25-year study now.
We're going to do
it again in 2019.
Most recently, I did
it with Cheryl Cooky
and my graduate
student, Michela Musto.
And the citation
for that is on here.
You can download that on
communication and sport
website.
And it's basically a
study that started.
And it was first
sponsored by what
was then called the Amateur
Athletic Foundation of Los
Angeles, later LA84 Foundation,
that Anita DeFrantz, who
you met this morning,
was the president
of for many, many years.
And it started out as a study,
a content analysis basically,
of the three network affiliate
news stations early evening
and late night news shows.
And then a little bit later,
we added ESPN SportsCenter
because we realized people were
getting a lot of their sports
news from SportsCenter.
Next time we do it,
we're determined
to add one more thing.
And I think it's
because we're learning
that younger people,
especially, are
getting a lot of their
sports information online.
And so what's the most sort of
general source of sports news?
I think it might be
espn.com, so we'll probably
add a content analysis of
that next time as well.
But the point is that we've
come out with this study
every five years.
And so we're able to track both
the quantity and the quality
of coverage of men's and women's
sports in news and highlight
shows over this period of
time at five-year intervals.
And what we've seen, it's not
a very pretty picture, frankly.
The top line there--
I'm colorblind, but
I think that's blue.
Am I right?
Thank you.
Is the three network
affiliate shows,
early evening and
late night shows.
And you can see
that 1999 and 2000,
we were starting to feel
a little bit optimistic.
And everybody was
asking us to interpret.
Is this an upward slope that's
just going to keep going up?
Suddenly it's up
to a whopping 8.7%.
And we weren't quite
sure how to interpret it.
But then it dropped off
again the following time
and then has plummeted
in recent years
to a much lower level in
the last two iterations
of the study.
ESPN SportsCenter pretty
much flatted around
2% of the time devoted
to the coverage of sports
devoted to women's sports.
Here's a sort of what actually
is covered in terms of sports.
This is combining the
news and highlights shows.
And as some people have
mentioned earlier today,
it's the big three
really for the most part.
Men's basketball,
men's football,
men's baseball are getting
the whopping proportions
of coverage on these shows.
And this is just
the 2014 numbers.
But if you look at this over
time, one of the things you see
is that that big
three has taken up
a larger and larger
proportion of coverage
over the years,
rather than smaller.
And I think part of this has
to do with a kind of timidity
in the newsroom in
these shows that they're
kind of going with the most
comfortable and familiar types
of sports.
I don't think with ESPN
this is probably an issue.
But with the TV
news shows, it might
be just like with newspapers,
the declining revenue
and declining labor to cover
certain kinds of things.
I read the LA Times every day.
And they can count on
at least one letter
from me every year
during basketball season.
Why aren't you covering women's
sports in the regular season?
If one of the local teams
gets into the NCAA tournament,
then they will
start covering it.
But the answer I usually
get from the editor is, A,
not that many people
go to the games.
And B, we just don't have the
staff anymore to cover that.
So we have to just sort of take
the little piece of news that
comes from the team itself
and put that in the newspaper.
And my argument all
the time back to them
is the chicken and egg
argument that people oftentimes
have with media about
audience building
and how when things
are covered more,
people learn more about them.
And newspapers are
an important part
of that web of information,
as are TV news and highlight
shows, that build interest
and a sense of history
and a sense of audience
buy-in to these forms
of entertainment.
Another thing that we
found in the study--
and this is again
just the 2014 data,
but it's very similar in recent
iterations of the study--
is that men's sports tend
to get covered even when
they're out of season.
There's lavish coverage.
And this is just a comparison of
the WNBA and the NBA coverage,
but we did this with
some other sports too.
But this is kind of a
good apples and apples
comparison in a lot of ways,
even though the WNBA season
is much shorter.
But you see a lot of
coverage, for instance, also
of Major League Baseball
when it's out of season.
The LA Times, again using
a sort of print example,
has front page sports
section stories
on USC football and UCLA
football in the springtime
during spring practice, and
then in months leading up
to the season building
a sense of excitement
about the first kickoff.
And women's sports, when
they do get covered,
are covered only
within the season.
And then it just kind of
evaporates and goes away.
So again, a kind of audience
building, interest building,
factor.
The most interesting thing I
think we have seen over time
is it's kind of
simple and easy to--
well, I will say this since
the research assistants who
have done the hard work on
this project over the years
aren't here with me.
Sitting there and watching
videotape hours and hours
and hours and coding it.
But the data are quite simple
for this sort of study,
the quantitative data.
But teasing out qualitative
patterns and changes over time
has been especially interesting.
And one of the things
that we've noticed
has been there's a decided
shift over time in the ways
that women's sports are covered
on news and highlight shows,
when they're covered at all.
And you saw those numbers.
They're not covered very much.
But when they're
covered at all, some
of the major patterns
that we've seen
are in those early
iterations of the study.
We saw a tremendous
amount of just kind
of making fun of and,
quote, "humorous" joking
and sexualization
and trivialization
of women's sports
and women athletes.
And there's lots
of examples of this
in earlier iterations
of our study--
a big, long story
on a woman who's
a nude bungee jumper off of a
bridge or something in a week
where there's no coverage
of any other women's sports,
that sort of thing.
And then by 2005, 2010,
you see a decline--
not a disappearance,
but a decline--
of that sort of trivializing
and overtly sexualizing
and making fun of
women's sports.
And the dominant
sort of narrative
for talking about women's
sports at that time
becomes talking about women in
these very well accepted kind
of, quote, "traditional"
sorts of gender frames--
women as the girl next door,
women as somebody's mother,
women as somebody's girlfriend
or wife, a woman athlete.
And so you see interviews,
when there are interviews
on the news and highlight
shows, with a woman athlete that
focus a lot on a high
profile woman or a highly
successful woman athlete.
You're a mother.
How do you possibly do it?
Talk about your child.
Tell us about your
role as a mother.
Which, of course, is fine
if they just did that
with men athletes too, I think.
And I tell my students who are
going into sports journalism.
I said, when you find yourself
in the locker room with LeBron
James after the
championship, ask him,
LeBron how do you do it?
Aren't you a father?
It just boggles me you can
be this great an athlete
and still have a child.
So I mean, a lot of this
is just about asymmetries
of the way we talk about and
talk to and frame women and men
athletes.
And then the most recent
iteration of this study, we
were very interested to find
a lot less, and almost no
really, insulting and
sexualizing frames
and presentations of women
athletes in these shows.
That had gone away
almost entirely.
And I think news
shows in particular
had been criticized
a lot for this,
and they kind of
pulled back on it.
But what we have seen is
a little bit of that kind
of ambivalent, wife/
mother sort of framing.
But instead, the
main finding that we
had in terms of the qualitative
coverage of women's sports
in these shows was just
that it was very, very dull,
really boring in the
way it got presented.
Not very much visuals, kind
of maybe just this brief,
monotone kind of report.
And so the comparison
looks something like this.
You have a few minutes
on a news show,
or a full hour on
ESPN SportsCenter,
where you just have bang, bang,
bang stories about men's sports
that have all these
popping visuals and all
this exciting commentary.
And it reminds me-- and we
wrote this in the article--
that all the superlatives and
the high action commentary
reminds me-- and some
of you are old enough
to remember this-- of the
old Batman show on TV,
the kind of bam, pow, wow
and that sort of action
stuff that you see.
And ESPN is really quite good
with this with their visuals.
And then, oh yeah, and the
women played today too.
And the voice
literally flattens out.
And so we call this
gender bland sexism,
kind of taking off on the
terms about racism that
are very similar today.
So you have really this sort
of active audience building
happening with men's sports and
very boring sort of commentary
on women's sports.
And it's almost as though
when they decided or someone
told them that they couldn't or
shouldn't insult or sexualize
women or trivialize
women athletes,
that they just decided not to
cover them very much at all.
And if they did,
they would do so
in a voice that communicated
their lack of interest.
Let me just say just
the last thing then
is that I think
we also, in terms
of textual analysis, that's
what we're looking at here.
But we also need to
think about production
and what it means to have
the kind of decisions
that are made in newsrooms,
print, and electronic.
And we need to think
about consumption
and how it is that people read.
Like that guy that
I saw in the grocery
store, how did he get
excited about women's sports?
And how did he make his
way into that program
and get so excited about it?
And SportsCenter to me is--
a research question I have about
SportsCenter is to what extent
men consumers experience
that as a kind of man
cave that insulates them
from the changes that
are going on in the world
around them that are all
about the empowerment of women.
So I'm out of time, and
I will stop at that then.
Thank you.
- Thanks.
Thank you for being here on
this beautiful Friday afternoon
and staying for
this final panel.
I'm really excited to be on
this panel with some of my idols
who have been so
central to the field.
And I am here to build on some
of the fantastic discussions
we've had thus far.
And I'll be focusing on
media representations
of transnational
female athletes who
compete in the United States.
And by transnational, I mean
either foreign to the United
States, on temporary work
visas, naturalized immigrants,
or the children
of immigrants who
continue to have connections
to their homelands.
Transnational female athletes
raise important questions
about the connections between
race, nation, and gender.
And I'm going to
base my statements
on my own research on Korean
female golfers in the Ladies
Professional Golf
Association, or the LPGA.
And I'll also suggest that
researchers and critics should
attempt to foster
relationships with journalists,
athletic personnel, and
feminists in other countries
in order to engage in a process
of transnational critique
when discussing
gender and sports.
So in 2014, a New
Zealander was the youngest
to win an LPGA tournament
at the age of 15.
And two years later,
at age 17, she
became the youngest professional
golfer, male or female,
to hold the world's
number one spot.
The golfer is Lydia
Ko, who is a New
Zealander born in South Korea.
The AP has referred to her as
a transplanted New Zealander.
And given the complexities
of globalization and sports
migration, she is referenced
as a Korean-born New Zealander,
as a Korean golfer with
New Zealand citizenship,
as simply a Korean golfer,
or as she refers to herself,
as a Korean Kiwi, or a Kowi.
Lydia Ko bucks the
notion of the apolitical
and post-political
Asian athlete.
She won a spot in Time
Magazine's 100 Most
Influential People
in the World in 2014.
And since the
beginning of this year,
she has begun to publicly
advocate for equal pay.
As the number one
female player in 2016,
she was the only woman among the
top 50 highest earning golfers.
And she ranked 44th
on the pay scale.
She made a minor splash in
New Zealand, United States,
and Korean language media when
she entered into the equal pay
debate.
And her advocacy for female
professional athletes
placed her in media
articles where
she was quoted alongside
the great Billie Jean King.
For Lydia Ko, gender
has become a category
for connecting her
various national, ethnic,
and racial ties.
As with many top
female athletes,
she underwent a makeover with
increased coverage and rising
fame.
She was signed by IMG.
And to kick off 2015,
she ditched her trademark
big glasses for contacts and
what is commonly referred
to as a double eyelid surgery.
She received the
surgery in South Korea,
where she also received
acupuncture for her wrist.
The Korean newspaper,
Chosun Ilbo,
stated in a rather
perfunctory way,
Ko said her caddy didn't
even recognize her
at first as she wore glasses
for about five years.
For a number of teenage Korean
girls and increasingly boys,
this procedure takes place
as a kind of rite of passage.
And in South Korea,
the inability
to recognize someone after
surgery is so commonplace
that the government has
mandated that individuals have
their national identity cards
reissued upon plastic surgery
to the face.
Pre- and post-op photos
like these of Lydia Ko
are ubiquitous on ads in public
spaces, and beauty magazines,
and websites, and on personal
social media where individuals
proudly post their own
pre- and post-op photos.
And so these makeover
images hardly cause a stir.
In mainstream Korean
context, the general attitude
towards these
surgeries is that they
are a positive
demonstration of aspiration,
if not necessary as
an economic strategy
to get ahead in a culture
that greatly values
appearance and a
culture that generally
assumes that the features you
are born with are not destiny.
It's fascinating to compare
Ko to the previous number one
golfer, Inbee Park, who is
also a history making golfer.
And this is a picture of Inbee.
Inbee Park is hardly recognized
outside of Korean golfing
contexts.
And while she was at
the top of her game
and will certainly be
in the Hall of Fame,
she made comparatively
little in advertising.
Park Inbee, or Inbee
Park, defiantly resisted
outside pressure to adjust
her weight and her looks,
pointing out that a
previous attempt to diet
had been disastrous
for her game.
She dismissed criticisms
of her lack of effort,
stating that money or fame
was never her motivation
for entering the sport.
Ko's surgery certainly
highlights the truism
that Mary Jo Kane
and Michael Messner
have proven again and again.
That while it takes athletic
talent to rise to the top,
female athletes continue to
be judged by their looks.
And that female
athletes themselves
actively participate
in the system
given its financial rewards.
Yet her surgery also points
to the common practice
of eyelid surgery for Korean and
Asian females the world over.
While it is certainly
a racialized practice,
it needs to be understood within
a Korean political economy
of images as an
attempt to project
a kind of global
Koreanness by adhering
to a particular
standard of appearance.
I remember being in Korea and
being told by a Mongolian woman
that I did not look Korean, but
rather more like a Mongolian.
And I have also been told
that I need to fix things,
as though somehow
there was something
wrong with my natural face.
This had more to
do with the fact
that I was not conforming to
the standards of Korean beauty
at the time.
And many critics
see Ko's surgery
not as an attempt to
look more Western,
but to conform to the
manner of Korean beauty
that's defined by Korean
actors and K-pop movie stars.
There are more important
distinctions to be parsed out
with respect to
the different ways
her gender and gender
practices associated
with her are understood
depending on national context.
Most Koreans consider
her Korean regardless
of nationality because of
her familial ties to Korea.
She is understood as part of
the education exodus of families
that leave to educate their
children in an Anglophone
country.
As a golfer, she is seen as one
of the many top Korean heritage
female players who
entered and dominated
the LPGA since the debut
of Se-ri Pak in 1998.
She was initiated into the
game by her golf-obsessed uncle
and aunt who reside in Seoul.
She is known to be obsessed
with K-pop and Hallyu stars,
or the Korean wave of
popular culture celebrities.
She received plastic surgery
and acupuncture in Seoul.
She enrolled at one of the top
universities in the nation,
Korea University,
in 2015, most likely
because they will allow her to
do her studies extramurally.
And for Koreans,
there is no doubt
that her great golfing success
hails from her Koreanness.
And her New Zealand
citizenship is
seen as a matter of convenience
or an economic strategy.
Yet she has been
embraced as a Kiwi
and has likewise been embraced
as a New Zealander who
has bolstered its multicultural
and immigrant friendly image.
She has been attributed
with bringing
the LPGA to the country.
She emigrated to New
Zealand at six years old
and gained citizenship at 12.
She is a national
icon and recognized
as one of the top
athletes of the nation.
She won at the
Australian Open in 2015,
which has always brought
a lot of pleasure
to the New Zealand
national public.
For New Zealanders to
win on Australian soil,
it's a big deal.
She won a silver medal in
Rio and was named Young New
Zealander of the Year in 2016.
Her gender is significant as she
is one of the few female Kiwi
athletes to rise to any
global acclaim, given
the overwhelming dominance
of the male sports of rugby
and cricket.
Yet even this identification
with New Zealand
is understood as fungible.
When asked about whether
she might represent
South Korea in future
Olympics, she has said,
"There have been
players in the past who
have gone back to Korea.
There have been questions to me
about changing my nationality
back to Korea.
But at the end of the day,
the players who did it
thought it best for them.
I'm proud to have New
Zealand on my bag."
She continued, "I
started golf in Korea
but did most of my
development in New Zealand
and where New Zealand
golf was very supportive.
And they're still
supportive now.
So it's kind of hard
to leave that behind.
Obviously when someone looks
at me, they see a Korean face.
I'm proud to be born in Korea
and to represent New Zealand.
And that's something
I'm fortunate to have,
support from two
amazing countries.
I'm a Korean Kiwi, or
as we say it, Kowi.
This self-naming practice
as a Korean Kiwi, or Kowi,
is reminiscent of
Tiger's Cablinasian
and highlights a similar attempt
to reduce any real tension
or politics around
her national identity.
Clearly a preoccupation of U.S.
Media and Anglophone golf media
is the idea that Asians
are actually always
originally from Asia.
And while she is a New Zealander
by nationality and has enrolled
at a Korean college, much of her
training takes place in Florida
and the U.S. And she spends
much of her time on a U.S.-based
tour.
Within the U.S.,
she is perceived
as one of many players
of Asian heritage
who are shifting the cultural
makeup of professional golf
and also opening
markets to Asia for U.S.
golf-related interests.
She has been signed by the New
York-based talent management
company, IMG, who famously
signed Korean-American Michelle
Wie in her teens.
And she has also been accused
of acculturating to the U.S.
and in an interview,
confessed, I
think I got an American
accent somewhere.
In the United States, she is
read through the lens of race
in ways that continue
to characterize
the presence of
Asians as temporary
and as perpetual foreigners.
As Asian females, they
are without exception
associated with their family
and often overdetermined
by their culture,
rather than seen
as world-class
individual athletes who
have cultivated their talent
through hard work and grit.
They are often infantilized
and objectified
as cute little Asians
available for a kiss,
as you see in this image.
While the LPGA presents itself
as the ultimate destination
for female golfers, for
many Korean players,
they have the opportunity
to make more in South Korea.
So they have to make a
very difficult decision
about whether to
remain in the LPGA.
Should they try to win a major
tournament in the LPGA, where
they suffer in anonymity?
Or should they play
in Korea, where
opportunities for making
money through sponsorships,
television spots, golf
clinics, and pro-ams
are much more frequent.
Because they are lumped together
as Korean female golfers,
even top golfers are largely
ignored by U.S. Sports media
unless they are number one
or especially attractive.
So what I've tried
to do is to highlight
various national contexts for
understanding how race, gender,
and nation operate in golf.
And I could go on, but I'm
just going to end here.
But I just wanted to
suggest that for academics,
journalists, and critics
in the United States
or in Europe or in the West,
it's highly problematic to make
a universal gender
critique about gender
inequality in sports
without addressing
the complexities of gender, and
race, and national differences,
and the scale of those important
identities for these players
themselves.
So I just want to
encourage us to think
about how to offer a gender
critique in sports that's
in conversation with critics,
journalists, and athletes
who reside in places where
these athletes are coming from,
or where they've migrated
to, and also who represent
underrepresented communities.
Thank you.
- Hi.
I'm Kavitha, and I guess
I'm ESPN's diversity hire.
So I think that we've
been talking about access
to women's sports all day.
And now we're obviously
talking about coverage.
And it's impossible to talk
about either of those things
without talking
about the women fan.
And the thing that underlies
all three of these things
is really that antiquated
notions about these people--
about these aspects of women
and sports, and their fandom,
and who covers them, and
how they're covered--
are still kind of
rooted in the idea
that sports are a place for men.
And the rest of us
are just visiting.
So the female fan who knows all
the stats and all the players
and has a ton of experience
talking about sports,
she's the outlier.
The female athlete who
is dominant in her game,
she's also the outlier.
Not everybody is Serena.
The idea that women can cover
sports analytically and not
just be sideline reporters,
that's also an outlier.
So I think that we have a lot of
these issues to kind of unpack
here.
And it all really does come
down to who the fans are,
and recognizing that,
and how that can
translate to better coverage.
So not to be too simplistic,
but this problem can kind of be
broken down to two prongs, the
fiscal undervaluing of women's
sports and the cultural
undervaluing of women's sports.
And the two are
really interrelated.
And I'm going to start with
the fiscal undervaluing
because I used to write
sports for Bloomberg.
And if you think the sports
journalism industry is
homogeneous, the finance sports
journalism industry is even
more so.
And ideally we could make
a purely moral argument
for why we should have equal
coverage, equal pay, equal
respect for women's sports.
But when you're trying to
make a purely moral argument
to bankers, that doesn't
really go over well.
So you kind of have to appeal
to that other side of them.
So management in the
industry-- and this
is throughout the industry.
And we're talking
television, radio, print,
online, everything,
including advertising.
And I'll get to that because
that's a huge driver of what
we're seeing here.
Management tends to argue
that women's sports don't
draw big ratings.
They don't draw high
traffic numbers.
They don't get enough clicks.
And they don't generate revenue.
And that's the reason.
That's the justification,
essentially,
for prioritizing men's
sports over women's sports.
People don't watch them, so
why should we force them to?
And why should we take up
valuable air time when we could
be airing things like poker?
The problem with
this mentality is
that it's also, as Michael said,
the ultimate chicken or the egg
thing.
If you give more exposure,
do proper promotion,
schedule games when people
would actually watch them
and are at home.
My God.
People would have
more familiarity
with these amazing athletes,
and with these games,
and with these things
that we want to cover,
and yes, sometimes with
the human interest stories
and the back stories that do
make some of these figures
really compelling.
It bears out with
the success of espnW.
And that's one of
the sites at ESPN
that I'm lucky to work for.
I also write for the
magazine and for .com.
But we've seen incredible
growth in traffic
in the last few years.
And as a result, we've seen
a lot more on-air coverage,
a lot more online coverage,
and a huge expansion
into how our women's content
kind of permeates other areas
of the company.
I can personally, anecdotally
attest to the idea
that more coverage will
generate more interest.
And it's the same game that
Michael was talking about.
I have a bunch of guy friends
who are always asking me,
help me get more into
women's basketball.
And I think mostly it's
just to get me to shut up
about women's basketball.
But so I'm watching
Mississippi State UConn,
and I'm texting all of them
to turn on the television.
And they do.
And I'm watching at home because
I want to watch in peace.
And I want to yell
at the TV when
I want to and everything
and have the sound on.
After the game finishes
airing, I go to my local bar
where most of them were.
And they had the sound on.
And they had the post-game on,
and they had all the interviews
on.
And everyone is going crazy.
And these were guys
rooting for teams
that they've never
watched before,
athletes they couldn't
name, cheering
at the top of their lungs.
And this was an
incredible thing to see.
It's not just the interest
that that generates, though.
This is very tangible.
Sorry.
It carried-- ratings
for that game
were up 90% from
the year before.
And they were the highest final
four ratings for the women's
tournament in five years.
It carried into the title
game two days later.
Ratings for the
championship were 20% higher
than last year's, and it was
the most streamed women's game
ever.
And that's important
because I think
that our generation does
not consume sports mostly
on television.
We don't get our news there.
We don't get our
games there largely.
We get them online.
So the fact that this game--
and the future of where we see
this industry going is online.
And that this women's game was
the most streamed game ever
is a testament to
how powerful just
being able to see how
incredible these games
and matchups and
exciting things can be.
And that game was everything
you want out of sports.
It was drama.
It was compelling.
It was unexpected.
It was historic.
It was improbable.
And those are the
kinds of things
that we can get
from women's sports
that we already know we
can get from men's sports.
If people knew how exciting
these games could be,
more people would
want to watch them.
And that's more
viewers, more readers,
and honestly most
importantly, more targeted
consumers for advertisers.
The difficulty here is
that it's really hard
to change the game
plan among management
without hard evidence.
And you can't really
get that hard evidence
without observing some
of the anecdotal behavior
that we've talked about and
also taking a leap of faith
that women's
coverage is worth it.
My problem with
that part of it is
that there have been
numerous leaps of faith
over the years that have gotten
men's sports the profitability
and the popularity
where they are now.
People always forget that it
took major league baseball
and football more than 50
years to actually reach
profitability.
And they did so with huge
government intervention,
anti-trust exemptions, tax
exemptions, some of which
still exist today.
Women's sports have not received
any of that kind of support.
I will say the WNBA has
had incredible support
from the NBA.
But come on.
We're not talking about
a league-wide anti-trust
exemption.
Similarly, 31 million
people watched game 7
of the NBA finals last year.
31 years ago, in
1986, CBS was tape
delaying NBA playoff games.
For context, I wasn't born then.
Neither was the WNBA.
The WNBA is 21 years old.
It was established in 1996.
So we're talking
about a sport that
can go from being on
tape delay to having
31 million people watching
it in a span of 30 years.
And we're not even
willing to give
the WNBA a chance for 20 years
of reaching profitability.
Besides that leap
of faith, there
are some tangible
arguments we can make both
to media and the
advertising industry that
drives our profit.
And we can do this
in showing that we're
shortchanging both women's
sports and women's fans.
And that that's shortsighted.
That we're leaving money
on the table when we do so.
So we did some
preliminary research.
We've been doing research
at ESPN for years
now on the women fan.
And I can share a couple
of things with you.
And the biggest number is
half of all sports fans--
literally half of all
sports fans-- are women.
That's 115 million people.
That's a huge
growth market there.
And that's something
that's being
overlooked that we have to stop
overlooking as an industry.
If you already have a pretty
well-established audience
and a consumer base,
I think we can all
agree it can be better catered
to, even among the women who
are currently watching.
But perhaps more
importantly, women fans
are growing at rates
higher than men's fans.
And in certain breakdowns
of the demographic,
the men's fans are
actually declining
in areas where the
women's fans are going up.
Women fans are also raising
in size and avidity.
Now what that means is
that the number of fans
who are going from casual
to average to strong, strong
sports fans is on the rise.
And those are the people
that we can absolutely
capture loyalty-wise.
The Title IX generation
largely accounts for this.
As you can imagine,
former athletes
tend to be the most
engaged in women's sports.
These women say, by
and large, that they
are sports fans for life because
they played sports growing up.
That's a sports fan for life.
That's exactly
what Christine was
talking about when she
was on stage with Layla
is that these are the
women that we should
be catering to especially.
As the participation rates
of female athletes go up,
so too will the fandom,
and the viewership,
and the consumer base.
So it's no secret that in every
facet of media, even sports
media, which has long
seemed untouchable,
the shift toward cord
cutting, toward going online,
away from print to digital, away
from digital to social media
and video is causing a lot
of media companies to try
and re-evaluate
how they can reach
new populations and new
viewers and new consumers.
And the women's market obviously
represents a huge potential
for that.
It seems
counterproductive to leave
the needs of a group of millions
of fans that's only getting
larger unattended
simply because we
don't look like what you think
a sports fan usually looks like.
So here's the point where I
have to interject with an appeal
specifically to
advertisers about the value
of the female fan.
I used to work at--
I interned at Nielsen Sports
doing consumer and viewership
insights.
And I can't tell you how many
times I was sitting in a room
with a bunch of
male ad execs trying
to convince them that, yes,
women might not drink the beer.
But they're the ones buying the
beer, so maybe don't offend us
in the commercials.
I understand where their
mentality comes from,
even if it is archaic.
We all know that the
ad industry tends
to uphold the male, 18 to
24 demo as its main target.
But it's finally coming
around to the reality
that, even if women
don't watch sports,
and that's obviously
a very dubious
if, we buy a lot of things.
It's not just the
household products.
We buy a lot of things.
We make those
purchasing decisions.
And that's really important
that advertisers start
to come around to realize.
Among female sports
fans, three groups
tend to be the most engaged.
This is one of my favorite
stats from one of our reports.
Women 25 to 34, African-American
women as a whole,
and moms with kids 6 through 17.
Women 25 to 34
increasingly being coveted,
they're coming around
to that at least.
They might be highly educated,
high-earning, single,
professional.
Or they might
belong to the group
of women that are getting
married, and having
kids, and starting families much
later than they were before.
Either way, they have really
high purchasing power.
Meanwhile African-American
women are largely
ignored all over the
place, whether it's
as consumers of products
or as consumers of media.
So that represents a huge
space that we need to tap into.
And then moms with kids
6 to 17, like most women,
make the household
purchasing decisions.
Ad execs have been trying to
market to mothers for years.
We see this with all the
Procter & Gamble commercials
during the Olympics.
Sports year-round can be
a way to tap into that
not just every four years.
All of this is to
say that there's
a market for female fans that's
rich and not fully tapped into.
But once you've cleared
that first hurdle
of convincing
people that there's
a monetary value
in women's sports,
you still run into
the roadblock when
it comes to the cultural value.
Women fans don't
watch women's sports.
This is a huge thing that
people always, always bring up.
And that's sadly true.
But I don't think it should
be the burden of simply
women's fans to convince
management, mostly
male management, that women's
sports are worth something.
Male fans do exist.
And they just haven't
been catered to,
the same way women fans
haven't been catered to.
If you grow overall the
interest among sports fans,
more women are going to watch.
And more men are going to watch.
It's not going to be stratified.
Because if you look
at the breakdown,
the way that women fans
engage with their sports
is very similar to
the way that male fans
engage with their sports.
They like the same
sports, in the same order,
the same amount.
But they're just
not being exposed
to the women's side of it.
There is a slight distinction.
While women do mostly
watch men's sports,
they do care that women's
sports are being covered.
And that's something that we
can really, really tap into.
Because they care that--
they want the game highlights.
They want the actual events on.
They want to watch
all of these things.
But they also want to
watch a female perspective.
They want to read a
female perspective.
They want the stories
about these women athletes
that maybe they can relate
to on a more personal level.
And that's a really
different kind
of way to attract these fans.
And that does come
to the coverage.
That does come to
the representation.
That does come to the on-air
talent, and the writers,
and everything like that.
All that need for respect--
and that's what your
female fan mostly
says is that we want
women to be treated
with respect in this space.
All of that brings us to
the cultural undervaluing
of women's sports and, by
extension, women's sports fans.
You can make all the
empirical arguments
for how covering sports
can boost your bottom line.
But they won't make
any impact until we
start to think of them as worthy
instruments of our culture
and entertainment.
The fiscal undervaluing
of women's sports
is based largely on
the perceived value
of women athletes as less than.
And that's a conversation
that's impossible to have
without talking about how our
society values masculinity
over femininity.
The age-old argument
against women's sports
was that athleticism was
antithetical to femininity.
We had all kinds
of crazy theories
about the impact of playing
sports on a woman's fertility
and things like
that, assumptions
about the limitations of
her strength and stamina.
For some, it was unnatural
to watch a woman just sweat
and exert herself.
Hopefully, the fertility thing
has been cleared up by now.
But many of those attitudes
abound and are often
used precisely to
devalue women's sports.
Women's tennis
players shouldn't get
paid as much because
they only play
three sets instead of five.
Meanwhile, the
women tennis players
have been fighting to be able
to play five sets for years
now and have been told that
they can't physically handle it.
So don't use that
argument against them.
Tennis is a great thing because
we have Serena Williams.
And Serena is just a
flash mob of every issue
that we've talked about today.
From the idea that anything
could be physically out of her
reach-- which I haven't seen
anything she can't physically
do yet--
to the sexism and
racism that is often
employed when talking
about her body.
Whether it's the
framing of her to fans,
whether she looks too
manly, whether she's
only successful and
strong because she's
taking
performance-enhancing drugs,
which is an accusation that
flies about with absolutely
no basis whatsoever.
But she's also
really interesting
because, in the context
of sexualizing athletes,
she owns her sexuality in a
way that isn't commodified.
She has been able to be an
athlete first and, yes, a sexy,
beautiful, could-be-a-model
woman second.
I wrote a column
when I first started
ESPN around the Olympics
about how attractive I find
Conor Dwyer, Olympic swimmer.
And I basically
used it as a joke
to kind of start discussing how
objectifying male athletes can
be OK.
Objectifying female
athletes can be OK.
The problem is we don't
do it in the same way.
If we did, if we started from
the same starting point, then
it would make sense to
do it in the same way.
But we don't.
What we do is the male
athlete is an athlete first,
and a good-looking guy second.
The female athlete is a
good-looking girl first,
and maybe you consider
her athletic ability
after you consider
how hot she is.
That's a really problematic way
of how we're framing things.
And I think that that's
one of the things
that we need to work on.
Serena's also a great
example for why we don't just
undervalue individual athletes,
but the quality of the sport.
Her success is used
against her as a marker
of how weak the field is--
the same thing with UConn
basketball.
You're talking about
two incredibly dominant,
winning programs and people
whose success is completely
used against them as a sign
of how weak their field is.
Now, the field is weaker.
But the solution isn't to
disrespect them or blame them
for that.
The solution is to
help the field grow
by telling girls that there
are other programs out there.
By showing them Mississippi
State instead of UConn
and by showing that
there are more options
to being successful
than just the one.
- Well, thank you,
all panelists.
I really would like to
start this discussion
among the three of you,
and then maybe later when
we get to the
public Q&A. And it's
this whole notion of why
aren't women covered more.
And I heard that on the
previous panel and now today.
And I want to push
us to say this.
It is true that
women are overlooked.
And it is true that
women are underutilized.
And I would argue from a
critical feminist perspective
that is precisely the point.
It is not, I don't believe,
that key decision-makers
don't understand that there are
market imperatives where they
could--
that there is this
untapped market.
I think that they
refuse to acknowledge
that there is an untapped market
because I have come to believe,
after being told for 30 years
that nobody's interested-- this
is what I believe the
biggest concern is
on key decision-makers.
And I want to hear what you say.
I think the biggest "fear" is
not that no one is interested.
But that if the audience
were given half a chance,
and women's sports were
promoted anywhere near the way
that men's sports were
reported, far too many people
would be interested.
And then they would no
longer be the center
of the universe monopolizing,
again, this enormously
important institution.
So I really want
us to stop thinking
about this in terms
of they're undervalued
and they're underutilized.
Because I think that
that's exactly what
they're supposed to be, so that
we continue to be marginalized.
So I don't know how you
want to react to that.
- I think there's something
to be said for that.
At the same time, I
think the money really
does speak for itself.
If you talk to these people
one-on-one-- and they're
not just male executives.
There are women in
management positions
who really do wish
that they could do more
to prioritize women's
games and air them more.
And they really do feel
hampered by the fact
that this is how
we've done things,
and this is how we've
been making our money,
and we can't see a future
in which this is changed.
I think there is something to
be said for the power structure
because that's who is
making these decisions.
If you had more women in
team and team executive,
league executive, editorial ,
executive management executive,
advertising executive positions,
then I think you would start
to see that sea change.
And I think you do--
when you finally do have a woman
in the room-- how many times
have we seen an ad or
a programming decision
and thought, there was no woman
in the room when that happened.
And I think that that's
really a function of that.
- Yeah.
But again, I want to push
back just a little bit
and say we've never given
women's sports the opportunity
to be covered in the way
that men's sports are
covered to see if there would
be a financial advantage.
And so, I mean, again, it does
become this chicken and egg.
And I would ask us to think
about what powerful forces are
at work that would prevent key
decision-makers from really
acting against their
own financial interests.
That's my only argument.
- If I could.
It's a great way to put
the question, I think,
because for me it's part--
I don't know as much
about the financial side
or how decisions are
made behind the closed
doors of media organizations.
But to me, I think
it's really important
to think about gender
and sport and gender
in sports media in terms of
broader, historical power
relations between women and men.
And the ways in which--
sport as we know it
as an institution
really took shape in
the mid-20th century.
And football emerges at a time,
in the post-World War II era,
when they were at least trying
to send Rosie the Riveter home
and re-asserting a gendered
public domestic split.
And then, within a couple
decades, feminism emerges.
And I think it's
right around that time
that football becomes
more and more popular,
as Mariah Burton
Nelson pointed out
with that great
title of her book,
The Stronger Women Get,
The More Men Love Football.
And I think there's something--
I interviewed a male
former athlete years ago.
And one quote that stuck in my
head and I've used many times
in things that I've
written is a guy who
I ask him about his workplace.
He hadn't played
sports for years.
And he worked in a
professional workplace.
And I asked him if he had women
working at his level or higher.
And he said, "Look.
A woman can do the same job as
me and maybe even be my boss.
But I'll be damned if she can
go out on the football field
and take a hit
from Ronnie Lott--"
that great defensive back
who was known for exploding
people with his body.
And if you could
have seen this guy,
you would have realized
that he too couldn't have
taken a hit from Ronnie Lott.
And about 99.99%
of men could not
have taken a hit
from Ronnie Lott
and lived to tell about it.
But Ronnie Lott existed
for him as a media image
to which he attached a sort of
ideology of male superiority.
And sport, then, came
to be this institution--
and especially
mediated sport-- came
to be this institution
that reinforced
this binary and this hierarchy
between men and women.
And Mary Jo pointed out
with such a great article
a number of years
ago that when women
start playing sport more
visibly, and we watch them,
and we support them,
what's revealed
is not that women and men
are from Mars and Venus
and very separate and totally
categorically different.
But instead there's this
continuum of difference
that's revealed empirically
between the abilities
of women's and men's bodies.
That knowledge is very
threatening to an entrenched
system of male entitlement.
And I'm really happy to--
some people were talking
earlier this morning
about what's it like--
Laila Ali was talking
what's it like for her son
to see competent girls
playing alongside.
And I had this experience
when my sons were growing up.
My younger son, I took them
all to all the USC women's
basketball games with me
for a number of years.
And I think there's a
whole generation of boys
that have grown up seeing and
even playing alongside girls
who are extremely competent,
and sometimes just beat
their butts at whatever
they're playing.
And it's the greatest
experience for a boy to have.
But as long as the mass
media isn't covering
this in any way that's
equitable or symmetrical,
then all of those kinds
of gains on some level--
because social
change takes place
at the interpersonal level,
at the structural level,
and at the sort of symbolic,
institutional level.
If it's not happening
at the symbolic level,
then in some ways it's
really just not happening.
So to me, that's why
it's so important
to think about the media
coverage of women in sports,
in part because of fairness.
If men have a right to do one
thing and get paid for it,
women should too.
But for me, it's because
media coverage of women
is part of this broader
system that's really in flux,
but it ultimately has to do with
the ways we think essentially
about women's and
men's bodies as being
different and
inferior and superior.
- And I just wanted
to add that--
I do a lot of my research
in Korea and Asia.
And in many of these
contexts, women
are a large part of
the media coverage
because they are
symbols of the nation.
And I think that connection
is important to think
about in terms of why
women's coverage rises
during the Olympics and whether
being a symbol of the nation
then supersedes the
fact that they're women.
And it makes it acceptable
during the Olympics.
And so I think that
it's important to think
about the ways in which gender
and nation work in sports.
- I-- well, go ahead.
- I just wanted
to add onto that.
It's a great point that
came up a couple of times
earlier today in a
different sort of way.
In the ways that, in
the United States,
coverage of women athletes
just really spikes
during the Olympics.
And we suddenly have
these female heroines
that we all know and
become household names.
And people sometimes
get very hopeful
that that's going
to kind of spill
over after the Olympics ends.
But it doesn't.
It seems to just kind of
evaporate back to a baseline
again.
And I've wondered how
and why that happens.
And I'd love to
hear from people who
work within the media about
how and why that happens.
But for me, what it says--
the story it tells to me is
that nationalism trumps sexism.
And I hate to use that
word as a verb now,
but it still works I think.
That somehow the way the
media coverage of women
happens between
all these Olympiads
is just shot through
with all this sexism.
But suddenly when we
have, quote, "our girls,"
who are going to go
and win medals for us,
and that we can all identify
in a nationalistic sort of way
with them, then suddenly
they become people
that we identify with and
lavish a lot of attention upon.
- But I think that
happens because it's safe.
It's every four years.
And it's not football.
And so I mean, I think that
that's in a safe space,
to be able to do that
where nationalism--
I don't want to
say trumps either--
trumps sexism.
I wanted to just-- we have 30
seconds before we open this up.
I wanted to ask
Rachael a question.
I assume that no male
Korean golfers have surgery.
Is that-- and the other
question that I have is
is there any backlash
or feminist critique
of these surgeries in
Korea and South Korea?
- I think increasingly,
men are doing it.
- They are.
- If they are in a media, like
a visible arena, a visual arena,
it's increasingly
acceptable for men.
And it's interesting because the
critique is less about gender
as it is about opportunity,
economic opportunity.
And so it's seen as a way
to advance opportunity
in an economy where
visual images are
so important to
one's opportunities.
So I think that there
is the gender critique.
But I think that
many-- even feminists
think that it's more
important to think about why
is the economy such
that individuals feel
that they have to do this.
- Interesting.
Well, we now want to open
it up to the audience.
And we would welcome
your questions.
Please just as a reminder,
just tell us who you are
and focus on the question.
- Hi.
My name is Deborah.
I'm a Harvard alumna.
But I'm here today
in my capacity
working with a small, all
women's college in the area who
is considering starting a
sports management concentration.
We've been doing
a lot of research
and would love to
infuse the curriculum
with this perspective.
We want to graduate
women who are not
only competitive
in the marketplace,
but also will be change agents.
If you had to make one or
two suggestions about what
you would like to
see in a curriculum
for specifically women going
into sports management,
what would it be?
- I think that they should read
the work that Mike and I do.
I actually-- when I first
got out of graduate school,
I taught in sport
management programs.
I think, again, it's central
to doing a gendered analysis
of what is happening here.
And I always take
everything back to power.
And the reason that
I say that is--
folks here in New England are
going to remember this story.
We talked about it at lunch.
Where a sports reporter for
the New England Patriots
was sexually harassed
in the locker room.
Her name was Lisa Olson.
And I remembered
sitting at NASSM,
which is the North American
Society for Sport Management's
professional organization.
And everyone was deploring
how horrible this was.
And it was horrible.
But the punch line from all
of the sort of academics
and scholars was, this is
horrible because nobody
benefits when this
kind of thing happens.
And I thought, no,
that's not true actually.
Men benefit when
these kinds of things
happen because then women don't
want to go into those locker
rooms, and women don't want
to go into those professions.
And so I think
that that would be,
I would hope, central
to any sort of analysis
in a sport management
curriculum.
I don't know if you
all want to say.
- I will say that it was
a class that I lobbied
to take at the School of
Sports Management at Columbia
when I was a freshmen that
is the reason that I am here
today.
It was called the
Sociohistorical Foundations
of American Sport,
and it basically
taught me about how sports could
be used as a cultural lens.
And that's basically how I
approach every single one
of my writings right now.
It was incredible to put what
can seem kind of frivolous
into historical context.
And simple things, like
baseball specialization
accompanying the assembly line,
and seeing how that was just
reflected in our nation's
history and global history
in some ways too.
I think that that could
be really important.
As far as the sexual
harassment thing,
I've been sexually
harassed in a locker room.
And it's never stopped me
from going back in, so.
- Thank you very much.
- Thank you.
- Hi.
My name's David Tannenwald.
I'm a freelance
writer in Cambridge,
and I really enjoyed
the discussion.
And one of the
things that struck me
is that politics is a
big theme in all this.
There were jokes about Trump,
talk about nationalism.
And I was curious what you
think about comparing inequity
in sports journalism
with journalism
in the political
arena, particularly
after the presidential election.
Is it better?
Is it worse?
Is it more of the same?
- Go ahead.
- I think it's worse
in sports journalism.
I think it's the worst in
tech and finance journalism.
Politics actually tends to
have a little bit more parity
than the rest of journalism,
that isn't culture and fashion.
And that's not to denigrate
culture and fashion journalism,
by the way.
I think that it's harder to be
a woman in sports journalism
with an eye toward
politics, which is kind
of how I approach my writing.
But it's a really fine
line, especially when
you're not a freelancer.
But I think that it's
definitely harder in sports.
And there are just fewer of us.
If you look at the
White House press pool,
there are more than two women.
If you go to a press conference
after a game as a woman,
you'll notice if there's
another woman there.
- Thanks.
- Thank you.
- Walter Harper, anthropologist.
I'd like to ask a two-pronged,
just one question.
It concerns or focuses
on the Williams sisters.
Is my sentiment that
what they both experience
is as bad, if not
worse, than what
Jackie Robinson experienced
when he broke into baseball?
I don't-- I'm just of
the impression that there
hasn't been enough
said about it,
especially when they say that
they look like a man or they
are men.
And then secondly,
what about the racism
against the Euro-American
women, or the European women,
that they play against?
It seems to me,
on many occasions,
that their racism is as bad
as what outside people are
saying outside of tennis
regarding the Williams sisters.
I haven't seen any journalists
say enough about it.
I've never seen a big
ad in the New York Times
saying this has to stop.
This is just unacceptable.
And that's why I'm
asking the question.
- Panelists.
- I'll have to ask
for clarification
on the second part
of it in a second.
But as far as Jackie
versus Venus and Serena,
I think if you look at
how the media has treated
Venus versus Serena, it kind
of highlights the racism
that they've experienced.
Which is Venus did
everything right,
the way that Jackie kind of had
to take everything in stride.
He had to be the gentleman.
He had to put his head down
and just play the game and win.
Venus is naturally
just a quieter person.
She's not a showy--
but the word that's often
bandied about is she's elegant,
and she's classy.
And the subtext is Serena's not.
Serena's a showy,
passionate person.
And that's one of the reasons
she's such a great competitor.
And both of them are
incredible winners.
But I think that if you look
at the different treatment,
and if you talk to fans who
don't think that they're racist
and hate Serena but
love Venus, there's
a very distinct reason there.
And that's because
of the expectation
for black people,
especially black women,
to keep their head down
and their mouths shut,
even when they're winning
at the levels that they are.
- Well, I also think you can't
separate the fact that you have
two very different body types.
And when you look at Serena
Williams and her body type,
it's enormously threatening to
what a woman's body should look
like, even as a tennis player.
And she has been resolutely
unapologetic about her body
and about her power.
And I admire her
greatly for that.
But I also think that is also
a huge difference between how
Serena versus Venus
Williams is covered.
- But that's my whole point.
What's the difference then
between Serena and Sarah
Baartman?
I mean this has been
going on for a long time.
- Yeah.
- But what concerns me is
there hasn't been, to me,
enough sentiment saying
that this has to stop and is
acceptable, especially when
little African-American girls
could be seeing all of this.
And that might prompt them
not to want to play tennis
to go through that.
- Yeah, I agree.
- Thank you.
- So I write about
this almost every week.
I've probably written 17
articles about the treatment
that Serena's had.
- And I've read
a couple of them,
but I don't think it's enough.
- Well.
- I've read a couple.
But thank you very much.
- Thank you.
- Hi.
My name's Barbara Wolfinger.
I'm a retired mathematician
from North Andover.
But I happened to watch
the semifinal UConn game,
and I rooted for UConn
being from Connecticut.
And I was disappointed they
lost, but very excited.
I mean, an incredible
game, so much so
that I even had to watch the
final and root for Mississippi.
Lost again.
But my question actually
relates to a question
posed by one of the
talking heads ESPN shows.
I can't keep them all straight.
My husband has them
on all the time.
Posed a year ago.
And the question was-- and
I was shocked at the time--
is UConn women's basketball
team bad for women's sports.
And the statistics
quoted earlier about
how many people
watched the semifinals,
and it was because UConn lost.
And how they lost, and how
exciting it was, and then
how exciting it made the
final game because UConn lost.
At least that's
how I interpret it.
So it made me think back a
year ago to that question.
Did the dynasty that
UConn represent end
up being bad for women's sports?
So I'd be interested
in your opinions.
- I'll just take one
first crack at that,
and then others can chime in.
Thank you for that question too.
I've been paying
attention to that too.
People have been saying
that about the UConn women's
program.
And as someone who has been
watching college basketball
since long before the
rise of the women's game,
I remember very fondly
admiring so much
the UCLA men's
basketball dynasty when
Lew Alcindor and others
were playing, later
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar.
And they didn't win quite as
many championships in a row
as UConn did.
But for a decade or 12 years,
they were almost always there
and won almost all the time and
had a long, long win streak.
I don't remember
anybody ever saying this
is bad for men's basketball.
Of course just
bad for basketball
because they wouldn't
even think-- it's
just men's basketball
at that time.
And so my sense is that
UConn women's basketball team
has raised the profile of
women's basketball greatly.
And yeah, I mean, I'm happy
that Mississippi State beat them
because I'd just kind of gotten
on with their story line.
I was happy about them having
watched them against Baylor.
But maybe it's good
for basketball,
too, that they got beaten.
And probably they'll
be back next year
and start a big,
long streak again.
But they're not going away.
So I think it's a
double standard that's
placed on a really high quality
program that, in my view,
probably-- and probably it'll
be really clear in retrospect
that this is something that
brought women's basketball up
to another level.
- Yeah.
And I would go with the whole--
not only the UCLA John
Wooden comparison,
but the notion of a rising
tide lifts all boats.
And one of the great things
that we love about sports
is a David and Goliath story.
And that's exactly what we had.
And the fact that Mississippi
State beat them was phenomenal.
And that would not have been
an iconic moment had they just
beaten any other
team but Connecticut
because nobody thought that
anybody would beat Connecticut,
and certainly not
Mississippi State.
So I mean, I think Geno
and they've been great
for women's basketball.
- And I just wanted to add that
the coverage of the UConn fans,
I think, has done a
lot for women's sports.
Because they're just as rabid
and excited as any other fans.
- Yeah.
I started to talk about this,
and then I ran out of time.
I had about a page and a
half left of things to say.
It's the same thing with Serena.
It's the same thing with UConn.
The argument is that the
field isn't good enough.
The sport isn't good enough.
And honestly, we don't see that.
As Mary Jo and
Michael pointed out,
we don't see that argument
made about Duke and UNC.
When was the last time we
had a Sweet 16 without either
of those teams in there?
Actually there was a statistic.
I wrote it down.
22 current NBA
players went to Duke.
That's 5.5% of the league.
So Duke is bad for basketball.
Are we going to
start saying that?
It's only ever used
against the woman.
against Serena and UConn.
I will say that
we love the drama.
We love the upset, absolutely.
And that did help.
It will help in recruiting.
And I think that
because you now have--
and again this goes
back to my point
that the solution
here to strengthen
the field isn't to
completely dismiss the sport
or to blame the dominant team.
It's to try and
elevate the coverage.
Because the coverage was
elevated because the drama
was so compelling.
You're now going to have high
school women's basketball
players considering
Mississippi State,
considering committing to
Mississippi State instead
of maybe UConn-- or not instead
of, but in addition to--
because now they know they
have another school that they
could possibly win a title at.
- Great.
Thank you.
- Hi.
I'm Arlen Baron.
I'm a senior at
Clark University.
I'm extremely interested
in sports radio.
And more often than not,
that's very marketed
towards the male [INAUDIBLE]
and can often be very crude.
And how would you break
the stigmatization
of women's sports and
incorporate that even
in that kind of
crude atmosphere?
- So The Trifecta airs
between noon and 3:00
every Saturday on ESPN Radio.
And it's hosted by Jane McManus,
Sarah Spain, and Kate Fagan,
and occasionally yours truly.
And I think that it's
really starting to get--
I mean, the show itself
is very successful.
Overall, we are having
a lot more exposure
of female voices, both on
television and on radio.
We see Jemele Hill is co-hosting
SportsCenter at 6:00 every day
right now.
I don't know what the
actual solution is, other
than to just give us a chance.
And we don't always talk
about women's sports.
It's probably not even the
majority of what we talk about.
But we talk about them
when they're definitely
worth talking about it.
And you won't get that
coverage elsewhere.
- There's a sports studies
scholar, David Nylund,
who's written a book
on sports talk radio.
And what did somebody
earlier today call it?
Sports screaming radio or
something, I can't remember.
But looking at it, I
mentioned earlier sort
of that I've been thinking
about SportsCenter
as a kind of symbolic man
cave, I think, in some ways.
And Nylund's analysis of sports
talk radio is kind of that too.
It's a place where
guys go to get--
not just kind of to have
fun, just to talk sports.
But what's happening
below the surface
is having certain narrow
conceptions of masculinity
reinforced through their
banter with each other.
So I've been a couple of times
invited to come on those shows.
And I did once,
and I regretted it.
And so call me weak-kneed, but
I say no thank you from now on.
I'm not going on those shows.
- And I won't do them either.
I won't.
It's just not worth it.
- I think it also matters
if it's a call-in show
and if it's not.
Because the ones
that aren't tend
to have more thoughtful
voices, and they tend to--
and the call-in shows
are literally just fans.
And this is what goes back
to the man cave thing.
A lot of what's wrong with the
male sports fan and the way
that we cater to him
is that he thinks
of these athletes as
substitutes for himself
and his own failed ambitions.
And he can't do that with women.
So when we don't
have call-in shows,
we don't have Joe from
Staten Island calling
to yell about the
Knicks, then we tend
to have more serious discourse.
- We have time for
one more question.
- Hi, there.
Thank you all for being here.
It's been really great.
My name's Connor.
I go to Tufts University.
I'm majoring in film
and media studies
and minoring in sociology,
so this has been perfect.
I have a question
for Miss Davidson
but also for the whole panel.
I was wondering how
you would respond
to the initial backlash of
espnW because it's obviously
a subset of ESPN?
And does that contribute to
othering women continually
because there's obviously
not espnM or something?
- So this is a really
interesting question.
And this is something that
we have internal discussions
about all the time.
The initial criticism of
creating W--and I was nowhere
near this.
I was still at--
I don't even think
I was at Bloomberg.
I think I was in college
when this happened.
But was that it would create
a, quote, "pink ghetto"
for women's sports and for
women's sports coverage
because it would be
siloed somewhere else.
And the answer to that, and
what we've seen in the numbers--
and I think I originally did
conceptualize that happening.
What we've actually
seen bear out
is that yes, a lot of the
women's content stays on W,
doesn't get promoted
on the home page,
doesn't get read
by the general fan.
But that content wouldn't
exist at all if W didn't exist.
And the content that is of
higher interest that does get
pushed out--
my columns, Jane's
columns, all the coverage
about women's basketball,
Mechelle Voepel,
our amazing basketball
correspondent--
would not make it
to the front page
if we didn't have a W.
We also wouldn't have
certain SportsCenter things.
We did a thing.
The ESPN the Magazine and W's--
W's editor-in-chief
became the editor-in-chief
of ESPN the Magazine last
year, Alison Overholt.
She was the first
woman ever to be
the editor-in-chief of a
sports magazine, a major sports
magazine.
Did a 20th anniversary
cover for the WNBA
that was nominated for
a major magazine award.
That wouldn't have
happened without W.
That wouldn't have happened
without leadership like
Alison's.
So I do see that
criticism, and we
do have a ways to go to make
our content more visible.
But I think that that
content wouldn't even
exist if we didn't have a W.
- Thank you.
- Well, I want to thank
all the panelists.
They were fabulous.
And also the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced
Study at Harvard University.
Again, it's meant a
lot to me, as somebody
who's been doing
this 30 years, to be
invited to a place like this to
have this kind of a conference.
- Thank you.
And it's our honor
to have you guys.
I'm Janet Rich-Edwards.
I am the director of life
sciences here at Radcliffe.
And it's my pleasure
to be able to do
a couple minutes of
wrap-up before we send you
to the reception.
We've covered a lot
of ground today.
We started with
Egyptian stickball,
with women handing
bouquets to male athletes,
and got to a place today where
we had Laila Ali and Christine
Brennan I think agreeing
that the glass is half full.
And I will say that for
women of a certain age,
we've seen a lot of change.
I can tell you that in
1970, small town Ohio,
where I was eight years old, I
really wanted to play baseball.
I loved the smell of the
gloves, the sound of that ball.
But they wouldn't let
a girl on the team.
So instead, I took
baton twirling lessons.
My little sister, two
years younger than I am,
got on that team.
It's very sad.
She still can't twirl a baton.
But it's made a big
difference in her life.
And I can say that my daughters,
45 years after Title IX,
are division 1 rowers
and marathon runners.
And those girls are not just
visiting, to use your words.
I thought that was great.
But this social
change is incomplete.
Women make up 55% of
our college students,
but 43% of our college
athletes, we learned today.
I was shocked that 43% of
NCAA teams, of women's teams,
are coached by women, only that.
And that only one out of five
athletic directors is a woman.
More depressing still, that
2% of coverage of sports
is apparently coverage
of women athletes.
It is good news that it's less
sexualized and trivialized
than it used to be.
So that's progress, but there's
a long ways to go there.
I think even in our bright
spot every four years,
the Olympics-- where recently
half of the athletes were
women, where the gold medals for
men weigh the same as the gold
medals for women, and where
we get decent coverage--
even there, 38% of the national
flag bearers are women.
A baton twirler
would notice that.
And only 11% of the heads of
the national missions, the Chef
de Mission, are women.
So it strikes me that this
is something of a pipeline.
It's a pipeline like
we see for academics,
for women in academics.
But it's a pipeline we
cannot take for granted.
We need women as athletes, as
the role models that they are,
whether they want to be or not.
We need mentors.
We need coaches.
We talked today
about speaking up.
We talked about the
roles of parents,
and a special shout-out
a couple of times
to the role of fathers.
We've talked about the
athletes themselves,
the current athletes speaking
up and the former athletes--
I think an increasingly vocal
and important voice both
to promote the sport, but
also to warn us of the dangers
we heard about today, the sort
of dark side of athletics--
the injuries, the
doping, the pressure.
We've heard many calls
today to generate
more data, more
hard evidence that
will serve to ignite advocacy,
data about who is watching,
data about who is playing, and
data-- if Parissa Safai's still
here-- about who is not playing,
which is very important.
I was also struck by our need
to lawyer up, the importance
not only of legislation
but of regulations.
The devil is in these details.
That's very important
for us as advocates
and a role for leadership.
And, of course, the
media, media that
destabilizes these
boxes of sex and gender.
And the role of
places like espnW,
which gets more coverage,
which will eventually
generate more interest.
I also very much liked
our rights-based framing.
As Stephanie Wheeler said, the
right to get to that starting
line--
whether it's disability, your
gender, or, as Parissa Safai
said, about poverty.
The right to true sport and
the right to safe sport,
these are communal,
socially-determined access, not
frills for the powerful
and the privileged.
And we talked about sports--
I was moved by this.
This was Anita
DeFrantz's comment.
Sports is an expression
of the humanity of spirit.
We talked about it being a zone
of excellence where confidence
and respect prevail, where
there's a sense of community,
and also of sport as a
microcosm of our world.
So at the end of
today, I hope we
go away inspired to enjoy
our rights, to protect them,
to advance them, and to
cheer at the top of our lungs
for our right to sport.
So thank you so much
for coming today.
Thank you to our many panelists,
who just hit the ball out
of the park.
[MUSIC PLAYING]